I remember one of the lines that isn't
it ironic that the people who've been
most managed and protected by
governments are the poorest people in
America all right very glad to have our
next guest you know why you know why
quarterblack why why I grew up with I've
talked about Thomas Olsen people who
were huge influencers when people ask me
when I do these shows and it's
completely unwarranted Fame people ask
me for advice which I'm woefully
completely ill-equipped to deliver and I
tell particularly young people who are
either in the entertainment industry or
want to go into media the book I tell
them to read is this next man's
biography fine enough not necessarily
one of his in his books that he's
written more is it more informational
more nonfiction his actual autobiography
which is called
give me a break I think you know who it
is John Stossel calm at John Stossel mr.
Stowell thank you for being here sir
thank you remember me so yeah I don't
know if you know this but they're two
people had credited my life to making me
a conservative I know you're more
libertarian my father and yourself
because of your segments on 20/20 after
TGIF you drafted in behind Sabrina the
Teenage Witch and I was just enthralled
your father forced you to watch 22 I
know he didn't he didn't you know what
it was I remember I was a kid and I
remember just thinking your
anti-authoritarian and when you jumped
into I don't know if it was the East
River was one of your segments I was a
kid glove it was a Hudson River okay all
right just a little cleaner than the
East River and the currents are not so
strong so I don't want to claim my junk
okay but ever there's a kid thinking
this guy's effectively a professional
smartass that's what I thought as a kid
I and edit really I started looking in
to John Styles more and I used to look
forward to it and if I had to go to bed
I would tape 20 20 and they give me a
break segments a lot of people don't
know before kind of when you started
actually going in a libertarian path
where a lot of people know you now with
this audience you were a consumer
reporter where you report on kind of
scams and and charlatans explain people
who don't know the history and how that
kind of brought you to where you are now
I'm a stutterer when I first fell into
this TV job I didn't want to be on the
beat with
the other reporters screaming questions
of politicians and at the time people
thought of the news as crime politics
weather disasters right a lot of people
still think that way but that left a
huge area for me
the stutterer to work more slowly add
and snip out the stutters which was
Consumer Affairs in psychology and
sociology and science and medicine so
much good stuff and as a consumer
reporter I figured part of my job was to
police businesses the cheating people
right and I viewed capitalism as most
young lefties do and I graduated college
my professors had taught me that
capitalism was okay it brings us some
stuff but it's largely cruel unfair and
we need government controls to protect
us from the capitalists and I totally
believe that bash businesses won 19
Emmys from my peers for doing that right
gradually saw that the regulation that
we consumer reporters called for didn't
help it just made life more complex made
everything cost a little more and the
cheaters kept getting away with it
they're still getting away with it the
people selling the penis enlargers and
the burn fat lay asleep pill careful now
careful now we have we have a lot of
sponsors on the show you don't know who
they are we might have some self
lubricating pocket catheter commercials
coming up - so let's just tread no red
light see some of your sponsors maybe
cheaters and the clumsy government will
never do anything he's full about right
and I turn to the trial lawyers and they
were worse they ripped off the companies
they sued and many of their clients went
home with most of the money and I
gradually woke up and became a
libertarian I saw the philosophy that
had made sense to me as a kid didn't
make sense I started reading the
conservative media but you conservatives
seem to want to go to war with everybody
and to pull and walk the police the
bedroom I didn't lay
that either don't launch me into that I
just started I was just selling self
lubricating pocket catheters I want I
want to enhance the bedroom activities
and I don't want to go to war with
everybody personally well there this is
how it how I perceived it 25 years ago
when I was making the switch sure and I
discovered Reason magazine and the
libertarian philosophy made total sense
to me yeah I know and I know you do a
lot of great work with reason and um I
sort of came into it a little bit later
right 20 20 TGIF at that point you were
kind of on the libertarian path I didn't
know what a conservative was the ever
nurse has a kid I just knew that I liked
watching you and calling people on their
BS and I inherently was conservative you
know I start out as an actor really
young and so my dad taught me about
taxes you know when you're 13 and my dad
goes okay this is your check from
Arthur's or this is how much is going to
go to socialized healthcare you learn
about it pretty quickly and I just loved
watching your segments and then I found
your biography and then that was really
the first time that I read about
somebody who was shunned by his peers
exclusively for his point of view you
talk about that walking through the ABC
offices and how you were treated
differently once you started sort of
going after big government or the
concept thereof kinks can you explain
that a little bit to people who aren't
as familiar with it cuz that must have
been really tough like you said
emmy-winning these people loved you and
respected you and then all of a sudden
some of them just no more noble rama's
and I have one sigh that's true once I
said government is often the problem my
peers just weren't comfortable with that
and Peter Jennings when he would see me
in the hall would do one of these really
as if I was poison to the ABC neutrality
because I had a point of view yeah I are
conservative they I yeah as we well have
seen since then there's no other point
of view at ABC everyone is completely
neutral
yeah they view themselves as completely
neutral of course there should be more
gun regulation of course abortion should
be legal it's just the water we live in
in New York City and they don't view
themselves as having a point of view I
think now
that there are MSNBC Fox CNN and people
are more aware oh I guess I'm on this
side or that side right then ABC they
were all on the left but they thought
they were in the middle well that's kind
of what this Trump administration CNN is
a good example you know ABC was like
where CNN is now CNN a lot of people
thought Fox is right MSNBC is left CNN's
down the middle you and I as people who
work in the industry know that that
couldn't be further from the truth and
now they're being showcased for what
they are that goes back to ABC did you
know did you anticipate that would
happen when you sort of made that
transition or did it did you sort of
learn as you go like you did with
government corruption I did not
anticipate that I thought that they
would say oh yes you've explained it to
me I agree I sold you because I wasn't
the conservative to be a conservative at
ABC was like being a child molester that
was just yeah no no no you'll be better
off being a child molester at least you
get a you get a made-for-tv film about
you
but yeah this is gonna be edited
completely out of context I'm sorry
you've had a long and storied career mr.
Stossel let me let me ask you this do
you remember so I was really nervous the
first time we ever met and I don't know
you probably don't remember our first
meeting in person I would have said you
came up to me in a green room I believe
yes okay I did but before that I think
it was Geraldo Rivera's show maybe and I
was on the panel of some talking head it
might have been it could have been like
Bob Menendez it could have been Lonny
Davis could have been Doug shown you
know one of those people at Fox it's
like the liberal who was on there for
some whatever reason you were talking
about the housing crisis and they were
saying it's unfair for Americans to lose
their house and I said on-air I was 22
at the time I said you know what's
unfair is actually my parents spent
wisely and they saved wisely and now
they have the money to put down in a
house but they can't get it because the
banks aren't giving out loans because of
the subprime crisis that was created
through government incentives in the
first place I think that's not fair I
think it's not fair to keep those people
in the house and keepa let my parents
out and you walked before we met in the
green room you walk and you told that
person I can't refer the person was
because I was so focused on you you said
the kids right that's what you told the
guy and that was a huge
accomplishment for me that I met you in
the green room and you told me I talk
too much in that order I I have no
social skills I burned out what is in my
mind but you know what it was very
helpful you said you talked too much and
I would say and then you said yeah I
like somebody you said you Steven you've
done I've seen some of your stuff it's
interesting but you're on camera talking
too much show the viewer more show them
what you're talking about as opposed to
talking a lot of that was budgetary at
the time you know was me with just a
fact than a flip camera but it was very
blunt but very constructive and that's
been actually foundational to the way we
do this program now so I thank you for
that sting oh you're welcome do I get a
cut there's really not that much of a
cut you know that's the problem with
this the fragmenting media we do okay
but let me ask you do you have anything
that really sticks out in your mind like
we asked Thomas Sol about this which of
his books were his favorite do you have
any report that you've done at one point
that reel or two or three that stick out
as your favorites because I have one in
mind what I want to hear yours first
stupid in America piece on the education
monopoly my first 2020 special where
title are we scaring you to death I
wanted to call it we are scaring you to
death but they wouldn't let two lefty
producers quit rather than work on that
show and I thought I was fired so that
may be my favorite because I thought it
would be the end of my career but it
rated so well that it was a new
beginning for me did that surprise
people at ABC that you rated so well yes
do you think they look we don't agree
with you but we don't want to lose you
to NBC not this special okay you can
only do it if we make an extra hour
available the Nightline timeslot to have
other people there to rebut what you're
saying and they assume that people
wouldn't watch it the executive vice
president said what are you doing the
stuff you're good at like diets and
breast enlargement
and I said and then they were shocked
that it rated well and that scientists
would write in and say finally someone's
saying these things right I mean I
always wonder what they thought at that
point because at that moment in time
there was no new media like there is now
really there there was there wasn't
really cable cable news didn't exist in
the capacity that it has now for for
decades I only knew and we didn't have
AM radio by the way in Canada I would
get to pirate it from Plattsburgh New
York if I if if I was lucky
yours was kind of that sliver of truth
which was really foundational for me
growing up my favorite one I don't know
if you remember this was you did a
report on Native American reservations
on 20/20 I remember that one
I remember one of the lines that isn't
it ironic that the people who've been
most managed and protected by
governments are the poorest people in
America yes well that's very profound
but I remember your smartass remark more
when I was a kid because keep in mind
that's sitting down with this guy please
tell me you remember otherwise I want to
seem like the jackass you said you know
you he live here with sorry I whenever I
do talk of about someone I do an
impression of them it's automatic and
you said you live here with running
water and electricity and the guy said
the white man has made me live this way
and do you remember your response this
is this okay I'll give it because to me
ever the kid I about peed myself
laughing in my living room in a
three-bedroom Montreal I said white man
makes me live this way and you said but
you're wearing jeans I don't know why as
a kid I just thought that boiled the BS
down perfectly you know was this First
Nations person saying they forced me and
he was wearing Levi's and I was the it
was the highlight of my Friday was
watching your segments well I'm glad I I
thought all of America would feel that
way but they didn't we quoted that line
for a long every time we'd go past this
Native American sort of will like you
talked about it like you've talked about
and why he will don't know this they
really have been crippled by the
government it is a very I've tried to
find it on YouTube and show it to people
it's been pretty hard to find some
segments are easier to find some are
more difficult but
really did highlight the fact that like
you said people who have been given the
most help from the government have been
ironically crippled by them and I think
that was lost on a lot of people maybe
you were just ahead of your time and
then you moved over to obviously Fox
News and and you kind of once you were
amongst allies did that how did that
change your life in your career did you
feel like that you could relax a little
bit do you feel did you feel like you
missed the hunger the fight of the
conflict a little bit what was it what
was the transition like well no the
conflict sucked I said dude the wanted
to do a piece on Obamacare and I had all
this good material I know nobody's
interested in free market medicine and
school choice the movement was just
beginning they didn't want to hear these
things Fox they love this stuff so that
was great
it wasn't relaxing because now I had to
do a half hour I mean now our show every
week and but it's a different kind of
pressure
you're used to it you're doing a long
podcast but yeah I'm not winning any
Emmys certainly not I was used I was
used to short edited pieces yes and now
well you do you do them all very well
and now you do a lot of them we have
b-roll right now rolling I don't think
you can just see me of your video on
Bernie Sanders in the online Empire and
I know you work with reason but you also
have your own YouTube channel so is this
what's the relationship there exactly
there code does it all go on your
YouTube channel or some goes on reason
80% of the views are on my YouTube or
Facebook channels 20% on reason and
donors give to the charity reason which
then gives me most of that money to make
these videos and and they're very
informative and I appreciate that
someone who's had this you know 19 Emmys
you said you've been doing this for so
long is now moving into new mediums and
listen we need more people out there on
YouTube a lot of conservatives have sort
of relegated this territory to the left
a lot of social media let alone the
entertainment industry and you're one of
the few people this video I particularly
like where you talk about the Bernie
Sanders online media
we went after Bernie really hard during
the election let me explain why I
remember when I was at Fox for a long
time I was telling them they needed to
focus in the sky more because Hillary
Clinton was gonna be the coronation but
Bernie Sanders was the movement
candidate and for people in my
generation was more important to focus
you know take the head off the dragon
not many other people have done that so
what made you want to focus on Bernie
Sanders and what do you mean by the
Bernie Sanders online media empire
simply because I read an article saying
Bernie Sanders is quietly building a
Internet media empire can I listen oh my
goodness he was and wait a second that's
what I'm doing I'm trying to explain
people that limited government is a good
thing and this idiot is spreading deceit
and he's winning yeah so I want to do
one of my videos on that I'm doing these
videos because my 28 year old son
convinced me dad no one's gonna believe
what you say about free markets at least
no one in my world as long as you're on
Fox and you don't need Fox anymore
because people are cut in the courts and
you've got a million Twitter followers
this Facebook there's YouTube you don't
need a network yeah you don't and a lot
of people obviously it helps to be
backdoored in with a name like yours you
know the name recognition because people
can then search you and find you and so
it leads credibility to these mediums
whereas you know a good example I've
talked about this we had Ralph Macchio
on the show which at one point you'd
think oh Ralph Macchio that's back in
the 80s no no the number one show in the
world
it was Cobra Kai on YouTube red was
getting 36 million plays he wasn't
appearing on Fox he wasn't appearing on
CNN he was appearing on this show worse
for a long time we couldn't get people
who were appearing on prime-time
television and that's how it happens in
a moment
sometimes that flip and we have a lot of
young people who do watch what we do and
I know that there'll be big fans of
yours just make sure you keep keep that
keep the smartass NISS thats what made
me love you as a nine-year-old I didn't
have gone the route of comedy but you
were you were a big force in fearing me
there I'm easily bored and so I thought
to succeed in TV I have to do smartass
that makes people laugh absolutely did
I'm asking this are you are you friendly
with Barbara Walters or can I ask some
inside baseball questions how did how
did how did she react to you because you
know you would have to sit at that desk
and kind of introduce and toss to your
segments was it it was her and Phil
Donahue I believe and then he was
changed out if I'm not mistaken he hewed
down sorry Hugh Downs I got the name
well you know generic white guy name old
guy what how did they react to you
because you were on air with them and
they would have to grit their teeth and
bear it and know the package you were
tossing to they were friendly and viewed
me as I mean Hugh was kind of is kind of
libertarian and was sympathetic and
would sometimes say well John I didn't
know that and Barbra viewed me as kind
of a an insect that she would tolerate
would calling her I mean she's a
remarkable person
she's just could have coasted at this
point of her career yeah but she worried
and obsessed about every second video if
she had a piece on I knew my piece had
to be shorter because she was going to
demand that her piece would get more
time and we would set him a waiting for
the people to fix the lighting and she
was obsessing over this paperwork I said
what are you doing I'm taking the
seating assignments for my dinner party
tonight so intensely yes you don't know
how important this is
Wow sounds like someone's taking those
late night enlargement pills you were
talking about and comparing to succeed
in the man's world but it was when she
began yeah why I asked because I know
you've always been a like I said a bit
of a smart aleck but funny quick and she
she's very remarkable in a sense of what
she's accomplished but she doesn't seem
to have a sense of humor or a sense of
irony sometimes and is that a wrong is
that an incorrect read I'm trying to
remember humor
you know you re you're like that the
news reporter equivalent to nor McDonald
your okay going into a room and just
making people uncomfortable
as long as it's truthful and I've always
really Annette you know that happened
with Barbara Walters and nor McDonald's
I don't know if you ever saw that on the
view was she got really upset with him
yo yeah he this is when when George W
Bush was elected into office and he was
on the view and we couldn't find this on
YouTube for years they scrubbed it
because everyone remembers this clip I
remember the who's a norm fan and they
said well what do you think is a
Canadian what do you think about the
recent election and all norm said he
said yeah and I think not judge Bush
good guy and that's a good time to you
know get murderers out of the White
House there and barber all took a well
whatever do you mean
yeah Bill Clinton didn't you hear he
killed a guy and she went to commercial
break and he was not welcome on the view
for about six years and I was going this
is norm this is what so I could only
imagine what the greenroom was like with
her and you I've always wanted to to get
some insight stories but it sounds like
you're being tasteful which I'm not
happy about and every we obsessed about
every second every introduction to every
story and there was not a lot of
laughter you know I can't imagine who's
your favorite person would you say to
work with in your entire career I like
some of the smart Fox people Stuart
Varney David Asman the ones who blame
libertarian candidate those are the
people I like working with most yeah
there are some a lot of fun people that
remember on Fox Business I I never spent
money but jut judged Napolitano was
always so nice with me I don't know why
he was so friendly and he'd yet I he
didn't know me but he was a very very
friendly guy and you know you were semi
friendly but helpful yeah well now I
don't feel so special good alright so
that is John Stossel calm the YouTube
channel John Stossel
at John Stossel for as long as they
still allow you on Twitter do you have
anything coming down the pike
specifically that you want people to
keep their antenna up for we're gonna do
something on the Cavanaugh and freaking
out about his being on the Supreme Court
we are working
on my charity that puts my videos in
high school classrooms and we have a
contest essay contest putting the
winners on who defend price-gouging
which is as Milton Friedman explains in
the video a good thing because that
encourages people to bring supplies
through where they're most needed we
just shot a piece on the new leave them
anywhere scooters
you know first we got the bikes yes we
talked about it on this show and I'm
glad you're finally bringing the bird
scooters all the liberal cities that
want to go green are banning the it
solves the problem of urban
transportation it's done now and they
ban it and they're fun they're really
fun and they're fun and it gotta be some
public square problems because people
write them on the sidewalks and crush
old people like me but weirdly their
brand in San Francisco yeah but they're
threatening in Washington DC I know we
were in Austin and we found out that
they were they were trying to ban it cuz
because Austin banned uber for a while
it's the one really liberal city in
Texas and I actually bought because of
that rideshare program I went out and
bought a high-powered like the three
times the power electric scooter wiped
out immediately but there are a lot of
fun and it is amazing you know but now
I'm gonna get off on the top I just
because I think these scooters are
incredible you wrote in your book I
think it's myths lies and downright
stupidity get out the shovel why
everything you know was wrong did I get
that title correct you've been paying
attention well it's one of my favorite
books the book that influenced me most
was your autobiography as a young sort
of I didn't really know I was concerned
I just wanted to read about you but that
book I often tell people is a great
reference book and you talk even think
of it as an autobiography it was just it
was how I became the scourge of the
liberal media after winning Emmy Awards
but it was just sort of a work on
biography I don't know I I enjoyed it
but then the myths and down a downright
stupidity this is a book that's great
because you laid it out and as a matter
of fact it's a big way we format our
show with myth and truth myth in fact
you really did it in a way that I
thought was digestible in the book and
you talked about price gouging if I'm
not mistaken I think you brought up
Hurricane Katrina as an example
afterward where people would just go in
and buy up all the batteries and that
gouging is a market
forced to stop people from just going in
and saying alright I'm getting every
single double-a because I can't afford
to buy every single one if I'm not
mistaken I remember that example and
that was a that was an aha moment for me
because I'd never thought of price
gouging that's very true and that's just
part one that's also a market incentive
for people to to leave their homes and
bring batteries to the disaster area
right yeah it's and it's one of those
things where you say it say price
gouging can actually be a good thing and
people go okay I'm pissed and then you
explain it you know you lead with the
fact that they don't like to hear and
I've talked to you you taught me a lot
about that I talked with my friendly
Dornier the day was fact we did a fact
checked a fact check of Washington Post
50 claims that they did and he is a
lawyer and he was going okay this is her
claim but here's the contacts and here's
the truth I said no no no read john
stossel's book read their claim their
direct quote then just go truth and then
explain the context people want to hear
it on the outset what's the truth what's
your argument and then you can give them
the details and he said okay that that
makes sense
so you really do walk that line
brilliantly an intellectual but someone
who makes it available to the masses all
right sorry I keep going I'll talk I am
a fan a lifelong fan john stossel calm
at john stossel thanks so much for being
here sir we really appreciate it and out
looking forward to seeing what you do
here on the youtubes Thank You Steven
all right that sets that's about a wrap
for today we'll be back tomorrow with
somebody I don't know who someone
[Music]